if the power of the right to vote was
truly made available
to everyone in america
it would change the future of this
nation
in 2019 i got a call asking if i'd be
interested in taking a meeting with
stacey abrams and of course i nearly
fell off my chair
i was like are you kidding me give it up
for
your next governor ladies and gentlemen
stacy abrams
stacy was at first very reluctant to
have herself at the center of the film
she said i do not want this to be the
stacey abrams film
this is a film about the fight for the
right to vote
after stacy's 2018 run in georgia
many filmmakers approached her to tell
that story
and so when she met with liz and i she
said i don't want this to be
about me it is the story of how the
people of georgia have been cheated
we anticipated that voter suppression
was going to be instrumental in brian
kemp's campaign
and we were right
there's always that concern if you focus
solely on one character
that you're not able to kind of pull up
to the
5 000 foot per view and and
look at the bigger history and how that
bigger history has informed this moment
her story needed to be the the beating
heart the spine of our story
that single story from which we could
jump back
into history and say this is how we got
to now
so stacy's story could not be written
off as some aberration some anomaly
you see it as the perfect expression of
hundreds of years
of history jim crow 2.0 that's what
we're saying
states implement voter suppression laws
all across the country
things like new voter id laws purging
you're knocked off the rolls
changing the voting boundaries in the
united states
the right to vote is the only right you
can lose simply for not using it
in our history in these periods of
expansion of the franchise
where more people are brought into the
democratic conversation
after a period of time there is this
snapback and a retrenchment and a
cracking down on that power
we've been in line for five hours they
said you've already voted looks like
several days ago
no i would have remembered that
thousands of people were told no
and didn't have the authority to demand
better the system that is supposed to
protect our democracy
didn't work the way it was supposed to
it necessitated this kind of
divide and conquer approach we would be
sharing
images and face timing in terms of the
style we wanted to be consistent
so we worked with our dp wolfgang held
to develop
a very specific look for the interviews
specific camera angles
and we shot them on a green screen and
then later went back
and shot the plates working with green
screen
allowed us to seamlessly
shoot our interviews all over and
to choose back plates that we
thought were in keeping with
the subject so for example what you see
behind
stacy is kind of a reflection of her
we're in a library it is grand
for the archival research we really
wanted to bring a feeling of archival
verite
to the filmmaking so even though these
were stories that you know might have
happened in the past that we weren't
shooting that we were licensing we
wanted it to feel fresh
something that was really important for
us
was to find images
footage that had not been seen before
but also
personal testimonials you know one of my
favorite sections
in the civil rights movement are
from people shot in the 60s
who are bearing witness to the history
it's not archival footage but i think
that's a reason why
our interview with andrew young was so
important he's one of the
last remaining lions who was
there an instrumental to the civil
rights movement
and his recounting of bloody sunday
you know really transports the the
viewer
so intimately and empathetically to
that moment it was ruthless
and brutal and and criminal
but it was what
it was what changed the south on voting
rights
a lot of documentary films use animation
we chose to do so in our film
specifically for a couple of moments
that
we had no archival footage for
rather than using talking heads we
wanted to inhabit the psychology
of those stories in a more creatively
expressive way for the story of maceo
snipes
a black man coming back after world war
ii having fought the fascists
wanting to vote in his own country who's
murdered for doing so
there's one picture of maceo snipes
we wanted to tell a really full story of
this man so we engaged our wonderful
illustrator diana ijeta
to bring that story to life election day
terrorism
was designed to provide the kind of
intimidation
that said if all of the pieces of the
mississippi plan can't stop you
we've got some bullets and a rope that
will
i attended avondale high school and i
became the valedictorian of my high
school
when you're valedictorian in georgia you
get invited
to meet the governor of georgia so as
stacy
as a young high school valedictorian
goes to the governor's mansion
and is denied access and
the guard tells her and her family no
you're not on the list and he won't even
look at the list
and her animated figure shrinks away
it really gives you a sense of what it
must have felt to
be young stacy and to be so
intimidated and to have her family
disrespected
[Music]
we finished our last interviews in the
beginning of march
a week later our entire post-production
had to pivot to virtual working
and as we were
editing we certainly saw that there was
a necessity
to find moments to include what it meant
to exercise the vote during a pandemic
we did want to include images of voting
during covid because i think
2020's election is an important beat on
that timeline
kovid was part of it these unprecedented
claims of fraud during the election were
part of it so we did want to have
images of a new layer of
voting struggles based upon a global
pandemic
the story is evergreen it's not just
about
what happened with the u.s postal
service
it is this long power play
of who controls the access
to the franchise can
our votes be counted
and what does that playbook do
to our democracy there are still forces
that are determined
to keep citizens from voting unless we
fight
for the right to vote our democracy is
put at risk
the fight over voting rights is
ultimately about power
the states have figured out how to stop
african americans
hispanics asian americans the young
and the poor from voting we've got a lot
of work to do we try to make history
the table bout to turn
the table bout to turn the table bout to
turn
yeah i've been flipping through my
timeline
trying to get my mind right my city
cried out
i've got to cool down but i'm under
pressure
now monet wrote turntables as our end
title song
taking the energy of the film and
her art her activism and pouring it
all into a song that's also
an anthem that speaks to change to the
table's surname
[Music]
i think it's a perfect alignment with
stacy's story where
the struggle is real and ongoing but
we're hopeful
but the song also doesn't sugarcoat the
struggle
she talks about raising her fist and and
the fight and the lies that americans
have been told
but it does give us hope
i will not concede because the erosion
of our democracy
is not right history is never a straight
line it's always a fight
we have taken people on this history we
have
ended on the hopeful note but now i
think
the lingering question is what do we do
it's about the right to vote there are a
lot of people who take it for granted
but then when they see that somebody's
trying to mess with them and take it
away from them it's going to make them
mad
and want to show up and i think that
that was also part of the
raison d'etre of the film
[Music]
the vote matters
you belong you have value
[Applause]
[Music]
you